i am here with my co-captain
co-author
of our uh cookbook rebel homemaker it's
fuller valdez
now
i don't know about you guys but i am a
humble home cook and i'm always looking
for shortcuts and sort of you know how
can i
save time is there anyone with me that
feels that way
okay
um
so this segment then is definitely for
you and we teamed up with ragu for a
super fun competition and we're gonna
put some other at-home chef to the test
for a cooking contest we're calling
how do you ragu
okay
tell everyone about the competition so
we reached out to three viewers who
aren't professional chefs but are still
known to whip up delicious meals in the
kitchen
and because ragu sauce is a quick and
easy way to skillfully cook delicious
meals that the whole family can enjoy
we challenge them to create a dish that
was unique and accessible that uses ragu
as the star ingredient well i have to
say ragu is something that we've grown
up with i don't know life without ragu
it gives me the cozies and i love it so
much and also
because it's a competition the winner is
gonna receive not only bragging rights
but one thousand dollars
all right let's get started our first
contestant is a self-taught cook from
rhode island
please meet roscoe
hi my name is roscoe gay i currently
reside in rhode island and i love to
cook i'm not formally trained but my
dish with ragu
is a braised short rib over smoked
buddha grits and this is a childhood
classic that my father used to give us
so let me walk you through my recipe
i have about a pound of fresh short ribs
add worcestershire sauce olive oil in
all-purpose seasoning prepare your
peppers onions and now in a skillet sear
that short rib once that is browned add
the short ribs and veggies to the crock
pot add in one bottle of ragu let it
cook and then in a saucepan now bring
water to a boil add in some of the broth
that's in the crock pot and add your
favorite instant grit then add in your
cheese and just stir put the short ribs
right on top garnish it with the green
onions and enjoy
hey drone velar i hope you guys enjoy
the smoked gouda grits along with the
raccoon short beef ribs
i'm like i'm ready i'm
so excited to eat this roscoe i love it
i just dug in i'm so sorry and i'm going
with the spoon because it's so
incredibly tender it's also beautiful
and autumnal beautiful job breasts
thank you
so our next beauty is bringing a little
bit of philly to our studio today this
is mike
hi my name is mike watson i'm married to
my awesome wife kathy i spent 39 years
in the philadelphia fire service and
retired of battalion chief prior to that
i enlisted in the united states marine
corps
and as everybody knows about the fire
service we make food in the fire house
philadelphia is known for their cheese
steaks and the recipe that i'm doing is
going to be the philly ragu pepperoni
pizza stick to start this recipe off you
have to cook that meat on a gribble and
you always want to season every layer
when you're cooking in the meantime
we're going to cook some pepperoni once
the meat's finished i put mozzarella
cheese right on the cooked meat and then
i put ragu sauce and i let the sauce and
cheese permeate the flavor the meat when
that part's finished i put on a real
good roll and we're going to put some
more ragu on it and work shredded
mozzarella cheese i'm going to put my
cooked pepperoni on top of that put it
in a broiler and when it starts to
bubble it'll get brown that's when you
put it out and you serve it who's up
joel clark come and get it
mike
i'm so excited to meet you guys to meet
you too now mike uh tell us about your
sandwich i like the cheese and sauce on
the cooked meat blend the flavors in
then put the meat on a roll more cheesy
sauce so every bite you take you get a
flavor of that ragu and that mozzarella
cheese well also a lot of people don't
have like professionals absolutely wear
it at home it's a really great way to do
it at home and i was really watching
like the layers of the sauce and cheese
i'd really appreciate that good girl
that's good oh please mike roscoe this
is really that you guys
these dishes are incredible
so
ragu sauce was created by an italian
mother with a family recipe from naples
italy and here's roxy with a twist on
her own family's recipe
hi my name is roxy raffles i currently
live in ulbridge new jersey i've got
three little ones i actually grew up in
romania so i decided to do a polenta for
you because this is a dish that every
person in romania is used to eating so
today we're making our ragu shrimp with
a cheesy polenta
things first you gotta get water to boil
add in our dry polenta add our
feta cheese and that's just gonna sit on
the side for the shrimp start with a
nice hot pan with olive oil add garlic
and ginger and put in the shrimp
add this beautiful red ragu sauce
start plating that cheesy polenta
spoon this ragu sauce with shrimp right
on top
add some fresh basil for a great little
bit of garnish i personally love to add
a little bacon on top i spread a little
bit of the thai chili sauce put that in
the oven for about 10 minutes and you
can just garnish it right on top and
that's how you make ragu shrimp with
cheesy polenta please enjoy drew and
pilar
put this in my team
[Applause]
it's so nice to meet you too thank you
now shall we
do you see that we say the same things
at the same time it's true
right the texture of the shrimp against
the creaminess of polenta is really
delicious that's a really good cook on
the shrimp
and the ragu sauce just like brings it
all together
um all right well we've tried them all
we have what are we gonna do palar we're
gonna have them shut off our mics i
think real quick while you and i chick
chat are we gonna give it we're gonna
quit and then we're gonna announce the
winner
this really sucks and it's really hard
but i gotta say this the winner's gonna
win a thousand dollars but whoever also
um is in second and third place they're
also gonna get 500
so
think that's the only way to approach um
a friendly competition here so the
winner is
[Applause]
your short ribs were really really
really well cooked but mike i loved your
sandwich and i thought your plate of
food um roxy was just beautiful anxious
delicious and hearty and thank you so
much to all of you guys for joining us
[Music]
you